it has gone from a formula chromium oh
three to the oxide chromium 203 use a
smoke alarm off yep they were meant to
put it off it's a new year I have a new
tie and Brady has allowed me to do an
experiment and it's an experiment which
I used to do quite frequently that's
once a year to undergraduate lectures
when I was talking about oxygen and
oxidation
unfortunately I'm now moved to a
different lecture course so I can't do
this anymore and it is about a compound
of chromium chromium trioxide and
chromium trioxide is quite an unusual
compound of chromium where it is very
highly oxidized so the oxygen has taken
a lot of electrons away from the
chromium which makes it very reactive
and the compound itself is a sort of
dark red color it's not terribly
exciting to look at but it looks quite
nice when you grind it up and when you
grind it up it starts going a bit redder
if your chemicals the wrong size this is
a good way of breaking it up and some of
these tools have been taken hundreds of
years to be developed so why should we
try and make anything better if you
grind up something it reacts faster and
in this case it might not really be
necessary but in the old days when I did
this the chromium trioxide came in quite
big flakes which really did need
breaking up but it doesn't hurt to break
this up as well so let's just keep it up
a bit in here and put it behind the
screen
and I'm wearing gloves because chromium
trioxide is quite a nasty compound it
can oxidize the molecules in your body
and is potentially quite carcinogenic it
can cause cancer which is why people
have to be careful with this oxidation
state of chromium so I should put the
lid back on to the bottle it's got nice
lid somebody's written the formula on
the lid the reaction I'm going to do is
to react it with ethanol an ethanol can
be oxidized to form an aldehyde fnow or
sometimes called acetaldehyde smells
quite nice and because ethanol is an
inflammable liquid whenever you pouring
out in flammable liquids you need to
pull them out from a small vessel if you
pour them from a bigger vessel if they
catch fire the flame can go up the
liquid faster than it comes out and you
suddenly have the whole bottle on fire
with a smaller vessel there isn't much
to catch fire even if the flame does
come up and the brother of one of my
students discovered this for himself
when he tried to jazz up his living room
fire by pouring some petrol on it and
suddenly found himself on fire and had
to roll himself up in the carpet to put
out the flames so this is quite serious
if you get it wrong I'm protecting
myself with some nice woolly gloves yes
okay are you ready let's go so nothing
may happen because it's an old sample
but let's have a look are you ready go
not bad not bad it's brilliant and if
you know look
the sample has gone quite a nice green
the green is chromium 3 chromium 2 O 3
it has gone from a formula chromium oh 3
to the oxide chromium 2 O 3 use a smoke
alarm off yeah they were meant to put it
off so I've set the smoke alarm off it's
very embarrassing because I told them to
change it and I'm the safety officer so
I must go and deal with it hi
you forgot to switch adul it's alright
I'm forgiven but don't do it again